[Music]
peter tatchell there's a film about you
about recently called hating peter
tatchell what is it about your story
your career that you think made a good
film
well the film came about because the
director christopher amos when he was
doing the research
was astonished to discover the level of
hate and vitriol against me
mostly of course by supporters of
various tyrants and bigots that i've
challenged over the years
so that's how the name came about
it was basically chris's work you know
he had total
editorial independence
my only real involvement was going to
moscow
um when chris
shattered me
when i attempted and did stage
a protest for lgbt plus rights on the
opening day of the world cup in 2018
um particularly against the persecution
of lgbt plus people in chechnya
but for me the motivation for the film
was very much about
[Music]
showing how to be a change maker you
know through my experience and my
actions
hopefully inspiring other people that
they too can make social change
did you have any reservations in
having a film about your life made or
was everything pretty much already out
in the open and this is just a
continuation of a career that has been
about role modeling change and
um serving as a
figure for others to inspire action
well i feel very humbled to have a film
made about me in the first place
uh given there are so many other great
social activists
um
but i think what's
you know was a real challenge in making
this film for the director was
how to whittle down
you know over 3 000 campaigns that i've
done
since the late 1960s more than half a
century
to whittle it down to about a dozen or
so key campaigns
so obviously things like the attempted
arrest of president mugabe of zimbabwe
on charges of torture
uh the interruption of the archbishop of
canterbury's
easter sermon in 1998
over church homophobia and so on the
film there was some criticism of the
film for
mainly representing
experiences of white male gay experience
at the expense of maybe other
intersectional voices do you think those
critics had any point or do you think
this was about your story
well inevitably if it's a film about me
it's going to be looking at my
involvement in
various campaigns but i think you got a
very strong flavor
during the film that i was one of many
involved in a campaign
so going back to the 1860s
my involvement
in the campaign against
the vietnam war
and for the rights of indigenous black
australians
was very much in collaboration
with others
so it wasn't either an exclusively lgbt
plus campaign
um nor was it you know a um
a series of campaigns that that took a
one-sided view about simply
white or british or european issues
the lgbt plus
movement in recent years has been
seen maybe to be a bit more divided do
you think that's
an accurate reflection of what's
actually happening or has there always
been divisions and that's just something
that's come more into light recently
well there certainly are divisions and
always have been divisions in every
social movement
what concerns me is when those
divisions become
sectarian
when they become abusive
when they're more focused on fighting
each other
rather than fighting the main enemy and
you know we have to
you know battle against
the huge prejudice faced by lgbt plus
people
um
less so now in britain than before but
it's still there you know the huge spike
in homophobic biphobic and transphobic
hate crimes is very worrying
but more particularly the global
struggle you know of lgbt plus people
around the world
and i think that
internationalism
is so fundamental that we cannot remain
content
while any queer person anywhere in the
world is being oppressed
and disadvantaged and so for me
even right back to the late 1960s
whereas others are very much focusing on
you know the situation here in britain
i always had an internationalist
perspective
you know this was a global fight so i
remember in 1971 organizing a campaign
against cuba's um roundup and
incarceration and labor camps of lgbt
plus people
which was very controversial because i
was on the lift
um but i don't brook you know
neither left wing nor right wing
homophobia you were selected as a
candidate for labour in birmingham in
the early 80s
do you ever think about how things might
have panned out differently if you'd
become a member of parliament and been
on the labor benches
well of course if i had been elected
i probably would have ended up
on the back benches like jeremy corbyn
and look where he ended up
um
you know it's
who can tell
the one thing i would say is that um
[Music]
maybe in some respects it was better
that i wasn't elected
although i would have liked to have
taken
my human rights campaigns into
parliament
but maybe being on the outside has given
me greater freedom
you know i've been able to do things
and sometimes in quite provocative and
confrontational ways where necessary
which wouldn't be so easy for a member
of parliament but a member of parliament
can
work to pass legislation that changes
what's happening in that country at that
time do you think
being outside the system meant you had
less impact and were more of a
figurehead
well of course
changing the law is only one aspect you
know we also have to change the way in
which institutions operate
and change public hearts and minds and i
think i've probably done the latter two
more effectively from the outside
but of course i've also you know had
some impact on legislation so the
equality act of 2010
that was an idea that i and a handful of
other people had way back in the late
1970s we were arguing for a
comprehensive equality law to protect
everyone against discrimination
and it took you know
over 40 or over 30 years to make that
law
um
and i think you know
i played a very small part in bringing
that about so even from outside
parliament
as with any social movement
i helped influence what happened in
parliament and legislation that was
eventually passed
what do you think the peter tattral who
moved to london in the early 1970s
would make of
the state of gay liberation and women's
liberation in 2021 in the uk and
internationally at the moment
well i can remember in
1969
at the age of 17 when i first came out
when i first realized i was gay and came
out
in my hometown of melbourne australia
there was no lgbt plus movement
not even any council organizations or
switchboards absolutely nothing
so
the only reference i had
was looking at the black civil rights
movement in the united states
and i can remember
thinking in my mind as a rather
ill-educated uh 17 year old
if black people are an oppressed
minority who deserve equal rights
then the same applies to lgbt plus
people
and that was
you know looking back that was that was
quite an early conception because the
idea of gay people as an oppressed
minority deserving equal rights was i'd
never heard it before and you know it
only really began to evolve later on in
the 1970s
i also remember
again based on
studying the black civil rights movement
calculating that would probably take
about 50 years to win lgbt plus equality
in western countries like australia
britain and the united states
that was a speculative estimate but it's
it's more or less turned out to be right
so
you know um chance and you know good
luck i guess
what is the work that you do and that
your foundation does
focus on in the next 10 15 20 years
well i've always championed unpopular
causes
um
choosing causes that others are not
focusing on or that perhaps don't have
the same
level of you know public support or
understanding
so you know internationally
i've done a lot of work um supporting
the oppressed arab minority in iran the
awazi arabs
who were annexed by iran in the 1920s
and have been under occupation ever
since uh likewise the people of
blochestan who were annexed by pakistan
in 1948
and the people of west papua who are
annexed by indonesia in the 1960s
these are
national liberation struggles that are
pretty much below the radar there's
almost no one else on the left who's
championing those causes
so that's why i choose to focus on them
because very few other voices
are supporting them
here in britain
one of my great you know
issues or a number of great issues
include you know voting reform you know
it's absolutely outrageous that here in
britain
no political party has won a majority of
the public vote since
1931.
every single government has been a
minority one including of course boris
johnson's election victory in
2019.
he won less than 44 percent of the vote
yet the tories ended up with 56 of the
seats
and an 80 seat majority
that is not democracy you know the
majority of people did not want the
tories the conservatives have no mandate
for anything
and you know the same applies to labour
you know back in the tony blair days
blair won
on a minority of the vote including his
great landslide of seats
in 1997 which is based on about 43 of
the vote
um so that's an issue that's very close
to my heart and it's becoming more
popular but when i began campaigning
for it back in the 1980s
there was almost nobody on the left who
would support it
um labor was and something still is very
tribalist the idea of you know
not being able to secure a majority
um which of course pr means you know pr
means you can only get a majority of
seats if you get a majority of votes
um you know a lot of labor people are
still very resistant to that
another issue i've championed is
economic democracy
um you know we all expect political
democracy
but
by which virtually no one is campaigning
for economic democracy
you know we live in britain in an
economic dictatorship
where all the votes are held
by major shareholders investment
companies directors and managers
the ordinary people who work in both
private and public institutions have no
say that is a form of dictatorship
and you know i think you know if we we
talk about democracy we have to extend
it to all realms of of life
including and very crucially the economy
and the final issue i would flag up is
of course the importance of free speech
the right to say what you think and
believe
now of course that does not include the
right to incite violence or to make
false damaging allegations against
someone or indeed to engage in
harassment intimidation threats or
menaces
but i think in our free and open society
we have to allow for the fact that
people may say things that are offensive
you know there's nothing in any human
rights law which says you cannot cause
offense that causing offense is a crime
um you know so
for example when it comes to homophobic
street preachers you know christians who
stand on street corners preaching
against homosexuality
obviously i totally disagree with them
you know i support protests against them
but i don't think they should be
arrested and treated as criminals you
know
they have a right to their opinion and
we have a right to challenge and change
it
um you know
progress comes
by challenging bigoted ideas not by
banning them you know we have to change
people's hearts and minds to show why a
bigoted opinion is wrong simply no
platforming someone or banning them from
speaking doesn't make their ideas go
away
they just fester
the best way to deal with bad ideas is
with good ideas
um across all those different areas it
seems like
if there's a thread it's giving a voice
to people who are voiceless you know in
different contexts um why has that been
your
life's mission purpose well people often
ask me what my motives are
and they're very simple and some i even
say corny you know i love other people
you know i love freedom justice equality
i want to see a world where all of us
can have
a free and equal place
i put my shoes
in
my put my feet in the shoes of others
and think that if i was suffering an
injustice i would want someone to help
me
so therefore i have a
moral ethical duty to do what i can to
help others
to work with them to amplify their
voices to empower them to
give expression to the fight they're
undertaking
so for example jeremy bamba has been in
prison for 36 years
over the killing of five family members
at white house farm in 1985.
now i don't know whether jeremy bamber
is innocent or guilty
but looking into his case i know he
never got a fair trial
masses of evidence was suppressed by the
police
never given to the defense
at the time of his trial and indeed in
his subsequent appeals against
conviction
now
i put myself in his position
if that was me
i'd want someone to stand up and speak
for me
um so that's why i do it you know i
think you know
we overcome injustice
by having allies and voices
to support those who are getting a raw
deal or who are victims of miscarriages
of justice or discrimination
solidarity is so so so important you
know
standing with others
you know if we all stand with each other
we are together stronger and we can
overcome
injustices and inequalities
[Music]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv